- What's up, we are--
- [Group] GOT7.
- Mark, what's wrong with you?
- You from LA!
(whistled tune over tuba music)
- 'Sup, guys?
This is Evan.
Today I'm here with GOT7.
(group shouts)
- My name is Mark.
- I'm Yugyeom.
- What up, man?
Bambam.
- What's up, guys?
I'm JB.
- Youngjae.
- This is Jackson.
- Jinyoung.
(upbeat, fast-paced orchestral music)
- Ohh.
(laughter)
- Okay, I like Look.
Cut the part where I said
I like (speaks in Korean)
(laughter)
- Seven Eleven.
- GET7.
- Bam.
- Second May.
- From today on--
- Today on--
- May second is the dab day.
- May second.
- [Evan] Dab and take a
picture and hashtag dab day.
- That's good.
- I like it.
(gagging and exclaiming)
(laughter)
- For us, me, Bambam, Mark,
we're like foreigners, you know?
We couldn't really communicate.
Even though we learned the language,
we still have to learn all the slang
and we have to learn the
inner culture for Korea.
To be able to--
- To fit in.
- Yeah, to fit in.
Am I good in Korean?
- Not bad.
- Why so serious?
(laughter)
- [Evan] Jackson, are you OK?
- Yeah, man.
You said we could walk around.
- [Evan] Yeah, you can walk around.
- I'm just walking around.
(laughter)
Around.
- I'm Bambam.
- What about you?
Everybody picked you.
- This guy.
Evan, let me ask you, if you can switch--
- From all of you guys?
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- Next question.
- [Evan] Next question.
- [Mark] This is the best one.
- [Evan] Best one so far.
- [Group Member] Mark.
- This guy, this guy.
Fortnite, Overwatch,
Battleground, everything.
- Crazy gamer.
- Facebook Tetris.
- Tiger.
- A turtle.
Maybe one day I'll be gone
and my son or daughters still can.
- Yo.
(singing)
(laughter)
- Of course.
- Superbowl halftime show.
- [Group] Ohh.
- We have these these lovely pieces.
We're gonna be handing these out to fans
who's going to their concert.
- [Group member] Don't eat
it, just keep it as present.
(playful orchestral music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.